this is texas but not as we know it
it should be a pleasant 10 or 15 degree
centigrade here
instead it's now dropping to minus 10 in
the day minus 20 at night
a state known for its sunshine and
desert now battling
ice storms and plummeting temperatures
we're talking about record-breaking
cold temperatures all 254 texan counties
have imposed a
winter storm warning that's never
happened before
president biden has declared a federal
emergency
freeing the way for disaster relief the
severity of the cold weather that is
about to be experienced here in the
coming days
is unprecedented there are power cuts as
the state tries to cope with a huge
spike in demand for electricity
despite its fame for oil texas leans
heavily on wind power
but now many turbines are frozen solid
millions have been without power that's
led to problems with deliveries of
covered vaccines
some had to be hastily distributed after
the storage facility broke down
and we've seen long queues at shops or
at least
at the shops that are still open
on the roads stranded cars and confused
motorists
across the state there's been a string
of crashes
and pileups not great in a country where
the car is so
central to daily life well in the past
few minutes the sun
has gone down here and the temperature
has fallen even further very quickly
and the city of dallas is really
struggling to deal with what's happening
here
the roads are a great example they
haven't been gritted
lots of drivers aren't used to driving
in these conditions
and look up there the lights are
flashing that's because the traffic
lights aren't working
a state known for its rugged sunny
confidence
now wears a very different look
shivering surprised
and nervous adam parsons sky news
dallas